le sénat de la république a décidé de
faire les états généraux de territoire
l'opposition sénatoriale
nous y participerons dans un esprit
constructif
néanmoins vigilants car depuis 20 ans
c'est nous qui avons réalisé les plus
grandes avancées dans le domaine de la
territorialité et notamment en donnant
aux communes la compétence générale or
ce qui nous inquiète c'est que dans son
discours de politique générale le
nouveau premier ministre a indiqué que
tout le monde de faire des efforts
financiers y compris les collectivités
territoriales c'est pas ça que nous
attendons de l'état nous attendons de
l'état au contraire que l'état finance
et pas qu'ils prélèvent sur les
collectivités territoriales
alors bien entendu nous allons
participer tant l'esprit que je viens de
vous indiquer et notamment parce que
l'acte 2 de la décentralisation
avait été réalisé par notre ami jean
pierre raffarin et nous mêmes nous avons
bien entendu prévu 12 points importants
12 points solides sur lesquelles nous
allons faire des propositions pour
l'organisation des territoires à
l'intérieur de la république
c'est cela dont nous allons ensemble
maintenant c'est vous le voulez bien
discuter